[Applause]
dr biden an honor to be with you as well
even for a cabinet member i got to tell
you being
in the east room is not something you
get to do every day and
certainly not often two days in a row
but about 24 hours ago with enormous
pride
i sat right about there and watch the
president announce a bipartisan deal to
make some of the most significant
infrastructure investments
in the history of the republic and it
felt good
i want to say that whenever i'm in here
i always think about when i first
saw this room first saw these walls and
and the paintings and the famous
gold curtains which of course was on tv
like everybody else on a small tv set in
south end indiana
i watch tv as much as any other kid
growing up in the 90s maybe watch the
news a little more than most kids
and learn a lot about how the world
works i remember
being 15 and seeing stories about
president clinton's nominee for an
ambassadorship
who couldn't even get a vote in the
senate because he was gay
i remember at 16 looking at that same
television set
and seeing the face of matthew shepard
who was beaten and left to die
because he was gay at that age i had
never even heard the term
lgbt let alone begun to realize that any
of
this had anything to do with me but i
watched the news
and i learned i learned that being lgbtq
plus was something that could cost you
your job
could cost you your life not that long
ago
well within the lifetimes of many people
in this room being outed
could be disqualifying from public
service any public service not just
being a cabinet officer
or a member of the military but being a
bookkeeper or an astronomer
for the federal government i wasn't here
for those days but
i became a military officer under don't
ask don't tell
ran for office in indiana time and again
facing that choice between
service and love between duty
and self my whole self and yet today
here i am here you are here we are
standing in the east room in the company
of the president of the united states
and the first lady
wishing each other happy pride
so us even being here proves how much
change is possible in america
so many lives have been changed saved
by the sustained advocacy the moral
resolve the political courage
of countless lgbtq plus leaders and
allies
some elected some invisible some
long gone some in this room right now
here we are but we have such a long way
to go around the world lgbtq plus people
face discrimination and danger
especially in some of the same countries
where democracy itself
has been on the back foot lately and
here in the united states
many basic protections still do not
exist
rates of violence especially against
black trans women are shocking
and disproportionate and researchers
found that last year two in five
two in five lgbtq youth seriously
considered suicide
there have been great leaps forward in
this country but there are reminders
everywhere
about what it looks like to move
backwards not just in shocking acts of
violence like the
pulse shooting that this country now
rightly commemorates
but in the everyday grind of politics as
rights and equality come up for debate
there's an especially dangerous
political strategy arising in some
states right now
as some politicians try to gain
advantage by picking on transgender kids
some of the most vulnerable people in
this country
there are consequences when politicians
and other leaders
respond to transgender people's search
for equality and belonging
by basically denying that someone can be
transgender at all
telling america that transgender people
do not exist
amounts to telling very real transgender
people that they should not exist
and if you were a person in a position
of responsibility
you need to understand the weight of
your words
you need to understand that if you go
around signaling
to people that transgender youth
shouldn't exist
transgender youth will hear you and some
of them
will believe you so this is a matter of
life and death
and supporting and celebrating our lgbtq
plus community
is a matter of compassion and decency
and it's a matter of national character
bearing on the question of whether this
really can be a country of liberty and
justice for all and i am proud
to work for a president and an
administration that believes
in that more decent and equal america
it's reflected in the very makeup of
this administration full of
extraordinary out public servants
including dr rachel levine
[Applause]
so many talented people whose gifts
whose gifts would not have been
available to the american people not
long ago
and when it comes to policy the biden
harris administration is working for
that better america every day
from ending the trans military ban to
vigorous executive action against
discrimination and harassment
to this white house's strong and
unequivocal unequivocal support
for the equality act which must pass and
we thank the congressional leaders here
for making sure
so to everyone in this room and everyone
out there around the country and
even around the world those youth who
wonder whether they belong
and especially to those for whom doubt
or fear or danger mean you still can't
live fully as your true self
know that a whole lot of us have your
back starting at the top and yes
happy pride
so with that speaking of our amazing
youth i have the privilege
of introducing to you an extraordinary
young man somebody whose strength
and advocacy and courage can inspire us
all
please welcome ashton mota
thank you so much secretary berge and
good afternoon everyone
my name is ashton mota i use he him
pronouns
and i'm honored to be here with you all
today i'm a 16 year old
black afro-latino high school student
from lowell massachusetts
i also happen to be transgender this
means that while i was assigned female
at birth
i've always known in my heart that i'm
the young man standing here before you
today
i transitioned just before the seventh
grade i decided to tell my mom on my
12th birthday
yes my birthday because in my head i
thought well she can't get mad at me on
my birthday
i was scared because i didn't know how
she would react but she told me she
loved me
that i was her child and she would
support me so i could be the person i
was meant to be
my parents believed that me my four
siblings and all
children deserve to be loved and
celebrated for who they are
most people take having a loving home
for granted but for so many
including for my two including for two
of my siblings
having a loving home can save lives
after coming out it didn't take my
family and me long to realize
and learn that there are many
transgender youth especially transgender
youth of color
who are not supported by their families
and therefore experience homelessness
two of my siblings are young transgender
women of color
and are a part of the foster care system
i've been with my family for a little
over two years
and i've witnessed first how surrounding
them with love
and for and affirming who they are has
allowed them to grow into the beautiful
souls
that they have always been it's simple
when children are loved we thrive
because of the love and support i've
received i've become a proud advocate
for the trans community
after i came out i fought a bill in the
massachusetts legislature
that would have harmed young transgender
americans
i also am a leader with the gender cool
project a nationwide movement that lifts
up the positive stories of young
transgender and non-binary people
by showing people who we are not what we
are
we are future software engineers
teachers
elected officials and change makers
these are the stories we tell
most people have never met someone who
is transgender when they meet us
see us and hear our story they realize
we're just like all other young people
we sleep in late we love spending time
with our friends
and we make our communities better
the truth is that there are hundreds of
thousands of transgender and non-binary
young people like me
who are thriving in our country but
today in america
the lgbtq community especially trans
women of color
continue to face discrimination
homelessness
and hate and trans teenagers and kids
like me
wake up to headline after headline about
bill after bill
that prevent us from joining a sports
team receiving health care
or even just using the bathroom this is
why
passing the equality act is so important
[Applause]
it will give lgbtq plus people like me
the opportunity to walk into the world
as our true authentic selves without
having to worry about discrimination
just because of who we are
or who we love i want to thank president
biden for the protections his
administrations has put in place
for lgbtq plus people nationwide
while we know there's work to be done
these efforts are deeply meaningful to
so many young people like me
president biden has always stood up for
his family and i know he'll always stand
up for my family too
mr president thank you for having our
[Applause]
back
[Applause]
so
my name is joe biden i'm jill biden's
husband
ashton thank you you seemed awfully
comfortable up here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know i uh i'm not sure i'll be
around but you know
if you're here just don't pretend you
don't know me okay
your story your leadership and your mom
is an inspiration
[Applause]
my mother here she looked to say honey
god love you dear
god love you what you do
what you did what you continue to do i
want to thank
secretary well first of all i want to
say
to chastain belated happy birthday jason
if you could hear us inside we were
singing happy birthday to him we got a
bunch of cupcakes but not enough for
everybody
and uh mr secretary thank you
you are you're the best man look our
presence here this afternoon
makes a simple strong statement pride
is back at the white house
for this community for our nation for
the world pride month represents so much
it stands for courage the courage of all
those in previous generations and today
who proudly live their truth
it stands for justice both the steps
we've taken and the steps we need to
take
and above all pride month stands for
love
you know being able to love yourself
love whomever you love and love this
country enough to make it more fair
and more free and more just you know
during the campaign tim gill and scott
miller went
one of them's here today i don't want to
embarrass him he always gets mad when i
do that
brought me and jill to visit the
stonewall inn
i wanted to go and they wanted they
offered to take me
we wanted to pay tribute to that
hallowed ground represents the fight to
ensure that all people
are treated with dignity and respect
just a few minutes ago surrounded by the
survivors of family members
who were we've lost i signed a bill
consecrating another piece of hallowed
ground the pulse nightclub
and i want to thank all of the members
of the united states house
representatives in
the united states senate for standing up
and making sure
that will never be forgotten never be
forgotten
the site of the deadliest attack
affecting lbt to lgbtq
plus community in american history
it's now a national memorial this month
on the way into the office i walk
through
from my from the residence to the oval
office every morning
i walk through a hallway lit with
rainbow colors of pride
which you'll have a chance to see in
just a few minutes
you'll see a candle carried during the
aids vigil
in the early 90s by a pair and a pair of
sandals belonging to matthew shepard
the reminders of how much this community
has suffered
and lost but also reminders of this
community's incredible resiliency
incredible contributions and credit
including
we just saw the national football league
in the national women's soccer league
all of you here henry munoz
and kyle good to see you man i had
i had the opportunity to officiate their
wedding
representative malcolm kenyatta worry
about
and dr matt miller they stole the show
at the democratic convention
and my friend sarah mcbride where's
sarah
sarah
sarah worked closely with my son beau
when he was attorney general of the
state of delaware and is now
serving delaware as well as one of the
first openly
transgender state legislators in history
senator
yes sir from our history making
secretary of transportation
and we have today the first openly
transgender person ever confirmed to the
u.s senate
you just met her dr levine
representation matters recognition
matters
but there's something else that matters
results results
i'm proud to lead the most pro-lgbtq
equality
administration in u.s history and even
on the very my very first day in office
the first executive order i signed was
to change
the whole of the federal government to
commit to work aggressively to root out
discrimination against lb
lgbtq plus people and their families
that was the first executive order
ordered our agencies
every agency to rapidly implement the
supreme court's ruling in bostock
which affirmed that civil rights
protections on the basis of sex
apply to sexual orientation and gender
identity
and as a result of that executive order
the department of housing and urban
affairs
announced that it would be take steps to
protect lgbtq plus people
from discrimination and housing and
ensured critical protection for
transgender americans experiencing
homelessness
the consumer financial protection bureau
announced it would work to combat
discrimination against lgbtq plus people
in credit and lending the department of
health and human services announced it
would
protect against discrimination and
health care services
and just last week the department of
education
made clear that title nine protections
apply to sexual orientation and gender
identity and for him to put it
and a moment ago i signed an executive
order
to advance diversity equality and
inclusion accessibility across the
entire federal workforce
the order directs the entire federal
government to eliminate barriers so
people from every background and walk of
life have an equal opportunity to serve
our nation
including lgbtq plus folks
and all employees in underserved
communities
look i also was proud to rescind the
discriminatory and un-american ban on
openly transgender service members
today we're joined by lieutenant colonel
bree friend bree colonel
[Applause]
one of the highest ranking openly
transgender service members
in the united states military lieutenant
colonel fran thank you for your service
to our nation
we owe you thank you and everyone who
has served
everyone deserves absolutely high
quality of health care
that's why i was so pleased that last
week secretary mcdonough announced the
department of veterans affairs beginning
the process to provide
more comprehensive gender affirming care
to our nation's transcend for our
nation's transgender veterans
we're also making a quality centerpiece
of our diplomacy around the world
we believe lgbtq plus rights are human
rights
in february i signed a presidential
memorandum establishing
that it's the policy of the united
states to pursue an end to violence and
discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation of
gender identity
this month pride flags are flying
as some of my friends in our last in the
obama bible administration who are
openly gay
they are flying in more than over 130
u.s embassies around the world
a powerful
[Applause]
a powerful symbol of our commitment to
safety dignity and
opportunity for all and today i'm proud
to announce that jessica stern
who many of you know as an lgbt special
q plus special envoy at the state
department
and yes we're also making progress but i
know we still have a long way to go a
lot of work to do
but we must protect the gains we've made
and fend off the cruel and
unconscionable attacks we're seeing now
to ensure that everyone enjoys the full
promise of equality and dignity and
protection
when i was vice president i was proud
although it somehow
surprised some people in the
administration at the moment
by the way i did tell the president that
i would not go out and
proselytize but if i was asked i would
not remain quiet
the president i was proud have called
for marriage equality
along with barack obama because at the
time i said
love is love period six years ago
tomorrow
when the supreme court ruled in favor of
marriage equality
we're all reminded of the white house
lit up in rainbow colors
shortly thereafter i went to new york to
celebrate with my friend
evan wilson and a team from at freedom
to marry
the joy was palpable but we knew then
as we know now that our work is
unfinished
when a same-sex couple can be married in
the morning but denied a lease
in the afternoon for being gay
something's still wrong
over half of our states in over half of
our stage lbtq
plus americans still lack explosive
state state-level civil rights
protections
to shield them from discrimination as i
said as a presidential candidate in my
first joint address to congress it's
time for the united states senate
to pass the equality act and put the
legislation on my debt
[Applause]
harvey milk was right when he said quote
it takes no
compromise to give people their rights
it takes no compromise to give people
the rights
and by the way this bill doesn't just
protect lgbtq plus people
it's also going to strengthen existing
civil rights protections for people of
faith
people of color people with disabilities
women in public accommodations like
doctors offices parks and gyms
i want to thank the leaders of the
congressional equity caucus for their
continued work to make it happen
the equality act will also help protect
against the
disturbing proliferation of anti-lgbtq
bills
were seen in state legislatures so far
this year
hundreds of anti-lgbtq bills
have been introduced to state
legislatures more than a dozen of them
have already passed
more than a dozen of them these are some
of the ugliest
most un-american laws i've seen and i've
been here a while
many of them target transgender children
seeking to prevent them from receiving
the appropriate medical care
for using the bathroom in high school
while they're with the one where they'll
be most safe
even preventing them from joining sports
teams with their classmates
let's be clear this is nothing more than
bullying disguised as legislation
[Applause]
[Music]
as i've said before many times
transgender kids are some of the bravest
people in the world
i mean sincerely you just saw it
with ashton and you'll see it with
several other young people here
it takes courage to be true to your
authentic self and to face
the face of this kind of discrimination
you know exist
it takes a toll we know more than half
of transgender
youth seriously consider suicide just in
the past year
these young people aren't hurting anyone
but these laws are hurting them
they've got to stop
hard to see son beau when he was
delaware's attorney general was one of
the first ags in the country to call for
legislation to establish legal
protections
on the basis of gender identity protect
to protect trans people
trans people and now
the department of justice says file
statements of interest in cases
challenging two of these
those bills that got passed explaining
why they're so unconstitutional
so we have to work we have to work
through so much in these areas to
support
seniors aging in isolation without
support
to confront disproportionate levels
of homelessness and poverty and
unemployment the lgbt community
to address them the epidemic the level
of violence against transgender people
especially
transgender women has been mentioned
before women of color
in the coming days my administration is
going to have more to say about that
and to finally eradicate the aids
epidemic
i'm not sure i'm allowed to talk about
this
what
our son beau was a decorated war veteran
attorney general you know of the state
of delaware and should be standing here
instead of me
came home from war after year in iraq
and before that six months in kosovo
and
what he did he decided he was going to
set up a foundation for lgbtq youth but
primarily focusing on transgender youth
and he took all the money left from a
campaign he was going to run for
governor and put it in and a lot more
because and is working with everyone
from ymcas
to all the all the all the areas where
young people can find some solace his
buddy chris coons and my buddy senator
coons
knows what he's done the point is
a lot of transgender youth those who
commit suicide
based on the studies his foundation has
done
do it because their mom doesn't
understand
because mom or dad says you can't be
here anymore
rejected
so folks we got a lot of work to do a
lot of it's basically public education
let me close with this when you go
downstairs and see some of the
smithsonian
exhibit you get a sense of a long
long journey and how long it's been and
how far we've come
you've come but how much further we have
to go
so this afternoon we celebrate but
tomorrow we go back to work
progress won't come easily it never has
we're going to stand strong stand
together
and i promise you we will succeed i
promise you
i said to folks earlier you know things
and where you
why i always get asked by the press why
are you so optimistic
you know as my neurosurgeon once said
i'm probably a congenital optimist but
beyond that
it's a simple proposition look at the
young people
straight and gay doesn't matter
they're the least prejudiced this
generation
the most open the most giving
and the best educated generation in
history
it's a fact in all of history
and look where they are look how it's
changing
it's changing in ways that in my
generation 270 years ago
you get beat up for defending somebody
but really and truly there's a great
reason for hope
and so much talent so much
talent can be unleashed by embracing the
lgbt plus community
plus community so i want to thank you
and say happy pride may god bless you
all and may god protect our troops
[Applause]
what's up
you